et
[Musique]
la terre est redevenue calme
il ne reste que les marins shadoks dans
l'eau que j'ai gênes et le gibier
abandonné malheureusement il est parti à
la pêche
et il n'est pas revenu il n'était pas
revenu car il était tombé au creux d'un
rocher sur une sorte de taverne de fond
de mer où les marins shadoks attendait
joyeusement la marée en jouant au poker
le givi leur avait raconté ses malheurs
qu'il était tout seul et qu'il voulait
rentrer chez lui sur sa planète
quelle planète à moudre à ceux qui n'en
connaissait l'une des planètes des
petites des moyennes des grandes comme
ça n'est le givi ne savait pas alors sur
la fin de l'après-midi les shadoks
requins ont ramené le petit sur la plage
avec le flou et la gégène leur a dit que
c'était un gibier abandonné et il leur a
raconté la malheureuse histoire
les shadoks requins pleurait et le marin
shadoks fut saisie d'une sainte colère
que c'était spontané
qu'on n'avait pas idée d'abandonner les
gens comme ça eh bien il allait leur
montrer les bonnes manières assez godard
600 keur dette cnra et sa crypte où
julie oui ils iraient nuit sur la
belgique il ramènerait le petit et il
ficherait aux autres une bonne
correction par la même occasion
et ça c'était une jolie mais pour partir
dans le cosmos et remettre la shadow
caravelle en l'air c'était une autre a
fait gégène heureusement connaissait un
endroit un endroit secret ou le cosmos
ont ce temps là et descendez à sebha et
d'où l'on pouvait sortir de la terre
comme vous voulez c'était une montagne
de montagne si honte que les choses à
son sommet tenait en l'air toute seule
et s'envolait l'heure du départ était
arrivé là shadoks caravelle et lancer
d'importants discours sont échangés bon
ben voilà at il oui voilà répond gégène
voilà voilà le film ah bon et bien aller
loin ensemble
oui c'est le alors au revoir
un cri eugène et on le vit pendant très
longtemps faire des six ou dix mois
c'est ainsi que ce jour là il ya très
très longtemps
les derniers shadoks et le dernier
gibier quittèrent la terre
et c'est ainsi que notre histoire finit
en principe
[Musique]